bill and melinda gates are getting
divorced those crazy kids just
ain't gonna make it they are asking for
privacy right now which is ironic given
that they
they don't seem to care very much about
anybody else's privacy and a whole host
of matters not even just tech but whole
aspects of public policy
however the reason the gates divorce
matters
and they're asking for privacy matters
is this actually is
not a private matter and the idea that
it is
a private matter lies at the heart of a
lot of our political problems i'm
michael knowles this the michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from kai
jukebox
who says if you don't like michael's ad
transitions
you are indeed transphobic so true i'm
so glad someone is finally calling this
out
you know the left left is always
redefining terms
so let's just let's redefine that term
right now too if you don't like my ad
transitions
you are a vile transphobe
good luck sleeping easy at night being a
transphobe if you do want to sleep easy
and a great way to do it
my pillow you all know how much i love
my pillow you
i know that a lot of conservatives love
my pillow because my pillow has
conservative politics
but as i've said many times my pillow
could be a communist
front it could it could be a front for
the chinese communist party i would
still buy my pillow products
if that's how good they are the fact
that they're conservative is just icing
on the cake
well now they have a new product called
my slippers my slippers are made with my
pillow foam and impact gel to help
prevent fatigue and made with quality
leather suede
i can tell you firsthand these are very
very comfortable you are going to
love them the whole family is going to
want them for a limited time my pillow
is offering 40
off their new my slippers 40 off
so you get the sheets the pillows the
slippers you get everything from my
pillow they're absolutely fabulous
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square and use promo code
dailywire you will also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets
the my pillow mattress stopper in my
pillow towel sets or you can call
800-951-716
use promo code dailywire visit
mypillow.com right now
or call 800-951-7163
we no longer believe we can grow
together as a couple
in the next phase of our lives
say bill and melinda gates in a joint
statement on their
divorce have you ever heard
more ridiculous boomer nonsense than
that
what does that even what does that mean
we
we no longer believe we can grow to grow
together you're in your 60s
bill is i think melinda gates is in her
50s a lady never tells
what does grow together like you're some
14 year old child
in school look i just got to find myself
i got to grow no you're married you have
children
you have you more than maybe any other
married couple in the world
or more than the vast majority have
built
something together but now you need to
grow to get what does that mean in the
next
what is the next phase of your life you
know
the next 20 years what are you going to
do you're going to start going to
woodstock or something
you're going to you're gonna really
explore and just no matt you're
married like cut it out ridiculous
boomer nonsense the boomers did this i'm
serious
no fault divorce was not permitted
anywhere in this country
until 1969. 1969 california of course
becomes the first state
to create no fault divorce before that
if you wanted to get divorced you had to
have a reason for it
because divorce is not just a private
matter because marriage is not just a
private matter
marriage is a public contract marriage
is a political act
that you go in front of people you stand
on the altar
you make these vows these permanent vows
before not just
all the people around you not just the
whole community which is
the real political aspect here but
before god
and then you have the temerity to well
this is just private it's not just
private
you don't invite all of your friends to
private acts whenever you do some
private acts you know that you want to
keep very private
in your own home do you invite the whole
neighborhood no you don't but marriage
is a public act the
state of california decided to make it
easier to get divorced in only in 1969
but for the vast majority of our
country's history for the vast majority
of our civilization's history
divorce was very difficult to obtain
when it was not outright illegal
the reason that england split away from
the catholic church
and cemented the protestant revolution
is because henry viii
wanted to get a new wife and the pope
said no you can't do that
so henry did he did not i guess he
didn't get divorced he just ordered a
nice sharp guillotine from france
and then had his new his new marriage
there have been some people in recent
years who
many many people in recent years who
have said that the conservative answer
on marriage
is to get the government out of marriage
altogether because of these
impulses to change the definition of
marriage or to weaken the bonds of
marriage or to make marriage mean
something very different than it does
get the government out of marriage
marriage
and and the family are the bedrock
political institution
if the government if the politics does
not have something to say about the
fundamental political institution then
it doesn't have anything to say about
anything it is just
an incoherent statement to say the
government needs to get out of marriage
marriage is the fundamental building
block of society
and our politics the point of politics
is
for us to shape our society for us to
make sense of our society
and all get along and live together
there is no such thing as a politics
that has nothing to say
about marriage but we see the weakening
of marriage through no fault divorce
this is a very bad turn of events do you
think society has gotten
much better since the social and sexual
revolutions of the 1960s
or has it gotten a little bit worse
maybe some things got better some things
got worse well
where are we now are we in a period of
ascendancy or a period of decline
we know that marriage rates are at all
time lows we know that
divorce is pervasive we know that birth
rates have absolutely plummeted we know
that social stability
is quite low just look at how they burn
the country down how the radical
leftists burned the country down last
year
little stability wouldn't be such a bad
thing and amid
this total overhaul of the institution
of marriage of the family
meghan markle is writing a children's
book about
i kid you not the importance of family
meghan markle the biological weapon that
the united states obviously
engineered to destroy the british
monarchy once and for all that's for
1812 buddies
we're going to send you right in there
and break up the the most
legally stable family in the world the
most
the family for whom their stability is
the most important in the world because
it has reverberation throughout the
entire united kingdom
meghan markle who broke up that family
is now writing a book about the
importance of family the book is called
the bench
it's coming out on june 8th
because we are shameless
in this society and have no idea what
we're talking about anymore
you'll hear a lot of people say look we
we we support all
all different types of families now look
it's just what we've done it's not that
we've destroyed the family we're just
now it's just family means a lot of
different things
no no family is a very stable thing
the family has a basis in nature
right when a man and a woman love each
other very much they come together they
raise the kids if you want to raise the
kids in a flourishing way
in a way that is just and is best can
most conducive to their flourishing then
you remain together in monogamy
you keep strong bonds throughout your
whole family that creates a strong
society and then you can have a stable
nation on top of that
and what we want is we want all the
political goodies we want all the nice
things that come from
marriage and family but we don't want
any of the work
because contra to what we're hearing
from
bill and melinda gates here marriage is
not just about
how you grow in the phases
of your feels man you know it's not that
it's about making a commitment
and recognizing your duty and obligation
and fulfilling it
before god and to a lesser degree but
still quite important
before the political community
speaking of children did you know
did you know that your children are
being exposed to
vile really sick sexual content
on television and in the popular culture
yeah no i'm not talking about all the
crazy
drag queen story hour stuff no i'm not
i'm not talking about that i'm not
talking about all the weird stuff that
they see on the cartoon channels
i'm talking about snow white oh yeah so
disneyland
is reopening disney after being closed
for seven zillion days
because of stupid covid and disneyland
has this snow right
snow white ride that has
according to this columnist in san
francisco gate
a big problem oh this is do you know
what the problem is
you already know because you pay close
attention to politics you already know
what ridiculous gripe
this columnist is going to have
the new ride includes more includes a
more comprehensive story line
and that's the problem the new grand
finale of the snow white enchanted wish
is the moment when the prince finds snow
white asleep under the queen's
evil spell and gives her true love's
kiss
to release her from the enchantment a
kiss he gives her
without her consent while she's asleep
which cannot possibly be true love if
only
one person knows that it's happening
haven't we already agreed that consent
in early disney movies is a major issue
the teaching kids that kissing when it's
not been established that both parties
are willing to engage is
not okay okay i can't
it's i do have to keep going on i can't
stop it's hard to understand why the
disneyland of 2021 the current year
no less would choose to add a scene with
such old-fashioned ideas
as prince charming kissing snow white
it's rape snow white is about rape
according to people who do not
understand anything about men and women
love
marriage family or anything else in
society
as to the matter of consent
it just is a pure plot matter
snow white is under this evil spell
where she's just stuck there forever
right i
i think that given the choice between um
remain permanently under an evil spell
and get kissed by a hot guy i'm pretty
sure snow white would choose the latter
i don't think that we need to
like have a survey i don't think we need
scientific and philosophical
investigations into this
it's better the hot guy should kiss her
that's a better choice
but beyond that what's really at the
heart here is that in our liberal
society
we have exalted consent to be not just a
good
consent is a good we have exalted it to
be the only good
to the exclusion of virtue which we're
told we can't know to the exclusion of
the good the true and the beautiful
which we're told that we can't know
anything about
only consent matters and we have debased
consent
to to involve a a redefinition of
liberty as licentiousness
an idea that we have the right to
consent to do all sorts of evil things
even if they harm ourselves or harm
society
because that's true liberty according to
the modern ridiculous liberal definition
consent is all that matters marriage
family
raising children building a life
together that doesn't matter the moment
that you withdraw your consent
you can rip up the contracts well if you
do that you rip up the social contract
to use the
liberal description of society and more
to it
you rip up society itself
very very perverse
ridiculous risible totally laughable
idea but it ain't so funny when you see
the social effect of this
which is societal breakdown and when
society breaks down you're probably
going to want to have some physical
assets like
gold well if you want to invest in
physical gold best way to do it
go check out acre acre lets you
subscribe to gold bars for as little as
30 dollars a month
michael how is that possible gold bars
cost more than 30
they do it's a brilliant scheme you pay
each month
and once your gold stash reaches the
price of their gold bars they will
discreetly ship acre gold
to your house acre is a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar
lets you invest in physical gold without
coming out of pocket all at once
and by the way you know how there's a
nationwide ammo shortage
well acre is crafting a solid gold 24
carat nine millimeter bullet for you to
buy
right now can't find anything like these
anywhere probably not a good idea to
shoot it i was shooting an m60 the other
day
belt fed fully automatic i'd probably go
through like a million dollars if i just
held that trigger on gold bullets
but really really cool product visit
getacre gold.com
michael right now start investing in
physical gold today make sure you use
that url because acres giving away a
gold bar
tweet or post while you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre
that's getacreal.com michael and thank
you aker gold for supporting the show
we were just talking about romance and
consent
and marriage well marriage is getting an
overhaul
even as you get into marriage tiffany
is releasing their first ever men's
engagement rings so
you know you know typically for those
for those youths in the audience or
those people who have remained single
who have been living under a rock
when you get married what happens the
man goes out and buys a ring and he
proposes marriage and the woman either
accepts or smacks him across the face
and says no
and then she puts the ring on and then
you go get married
and then you can now now both parties
wear
a wedding ring though that wasn't always
the case but
only the woman wears the engagement ring
well that's changing
i have had um so i've got to watch my
words here i've had some liberal friends
of mine
who are men engaged in this process
already
the men have worn us an engagement ring
because they say well if the woman wears
an engagement ring i should wear an
engagement ring too
because men and women are exactly the
same and completely indistinguishable so
of course whatever the woman does the
man has to do
whatever the man does the woman has to
do
okay i don't don't agree with that
approach don't agree with that
anthropology but i understand it
i understand the the reasoning there now
tiffany by coming out and saying here is
a men's engagement ring
they are taking this beyond a sort of
personal eccentricity and saying this
could be a new social tradition this
could be a new
aspect of proposing now
the the men's engagement rings it's
called the charles charles tiffany
and it includes emerald cut and round
diamonds up to five carats so i don't
you'd have to be pretty blingy here who
is this aimed at
for the straight fellas in the audience
would you wear the charles tiffany
engagement ring
probably not right but i don't think
that
i don't think straight guys are the
audience here maybe some
feminist guys who think that men and
women have to do exactly the same thing
but
i think it's probably the reason for
this is because we have now from the
supreme court redefined marriage
to include not just monogamous
unions of husbands and wives but
also monogamous unions of the same sex
and so because of this if you know if
you're a
a man proposing to another man it's a
little who's going to do it which guy is
going to do it if you're now saying that
we are going to
redefine and expand the institution of
marriage to include monogamous same-sex
unions
it does raise a lot of questions because
sexual difference has always been
important to marriage it's always been
at the heart of marriage
even just at the basic question who's
going to propose the marriage and who's
going to accept the marriage
you have to try to work that sort of
thing out and who gets the ring and do
we both get the ring
this is the one area i've pointed out on
the show and other conservatives have
pointed this out too
that the transgender ideology undermines
the homosexual rights ideology
and it undermines them because gay
rights is very simple
right we're born this way some boys like
some boys like girls some boys like boys
and there's really nothing we can do to
change that desire so
society should be more accepting of that
okay totally understand that
and then the transgender ideology comes
in and says actually there's no such
thing as boys or girls and boys can
become girls and girls can become boys
and everything's mutable
well that so much for the born this way
so much for the you can't change that so
much for the orientation that undercuts
it
but there is one area where the two link
up and that is on
the redefinition of marriage because if
if the argument for the redefinition of
marriage which you saw from the supreme
court
is that m plus w
equals m plus m then m has to equal w
they have to be indiscernible they have
to be exactly the same and
if that is the case then you're going to
see a lot more
social rituals such as the tiffany men's
engagement ring
you're going to see a social push
to take away that which is particular
and peculiar to men
and that which is particular to women
it's all going to have to be
the same but anyone who's ever been
in a marriage knows that it's not the
same i've got my cute little newborn kid
at home
could i nurture that kid no to a degree
i can i can play with him i can kiss him
i can say hey buddy you know and i can
have a nice time and i can even give him
a bottle every now and again
but i cannot provide for that baby what
sweet little elisa can provide for that
baby because sweet little alisa is a
lady and i am a grunting
knuckle-dragging brute
and the relationship of a baby of any
person to his mother is different than
the relationship
to his father and that's the way it is
and no amount of social engineering
is ever going to change that and
by the way for the for the gay guys in
the audience and ladies too
you know i don't want to exclude the
ladies here i have had
many of my gay friends tell me
that when they are in a relationship the
gender roles sort of come out there too
some guy is a little more like the
traditional guy some guy is a little
more like the traditional
girl in the way they interact and the
way they cook and the way they whatever
because those things come from nature
and then civilization
has developed them so of course there is
a social aspect to our sex just as there
is a biological aspect
but those two things are connected and
in this culture if we're going to just
deny that
entirely then things are going to go a
little bit kooky
throughout all aspects of the society
and and we can make ourselves feel
better and say this is all just it's all
just private michael what do you care
what do you care getting back to the
inciting incident here what do you care
if bill and melinda gates get divorced
i care quite a lot i care a lot if
anybody gets divorced
because that's people breaking their
contract and their pledge
not just to one another and not even
just to god i suppose that's between
the parties involved there but they're
breaking a pledge to me
they're breaking a pledge to society
they're breaking a pledge to their
children
they're breaking a pledge to
the whole culture that they will do
their part
and i know it's a fallen world and these
things happen
but the question is here are we going to
encourage that sort of thing or are we
going to discourage that sort of thing
and the argument made not just by the
left but made by the right now as well
because the right has adopted
the ridiculous libertine redefinition of
the whole culture
that the left has forced it upon us this
is by the way the topic of my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now by the
way for pre-order
because we've adopted that language we
don't have any
philosophical tools at our disposal to
argue for the conservation of culture we
can't do it that's why we don't conserve
anything
that's one of the reasons why we don't
conserve anything
private decisions have public
consequences
and vice versa this is what you're
hearing all the time about the vaccine
this is the central disagreement at the
heart of the vaccine issue the vaccine
passports
the whole public health tyranny to what
degree does the public
have the right to say something about
your private decisions to what extent
are your private decisions
public joe biden has an important
insight about this
he says if you don't get the vaccine
we're going to die you're putting people
at risk of dying i also want to thank
the 105 million americans
of every background who are fully
protected from one of the deadliest
pandemics in our history
you know there's a lot of misinformation
out there but there's one
fact i want every american to know
people who are not fully vaccinated
can still die every day from covert 19.
look at the folks in your community have
gotten vaccinated
and are getting back to living their
lives their full lives
look at the grandparents united with
their grandchildren
friends getting together again this is
your choice
it's life and death this is your choice
life and death there were people
he actually made a true statement here
it's a rare fact for joe biden
there are people who don't have the
vaccine who are dying every day
and therefore because of the fear of
death he's going to scare you into doing
whatever he says
i'm not taking the arch libertarian
position here
that the government never has anything
to say about vaccines
i'm not taking that i'm also not taking
the leftist position that you all need
to get this this vaccine immediately
i'm taking the prudential position that
you should assess risk
to yourself and society and make a
reasonable decision i guess that's i
guess that's the joe rogan position
and i know you're not allowed to take
that anymore but
that to me seems to make a lot of sense
prudence is a conservative virtue
even though we seem to have forgotten
about it but i'm going to go further i
think what lies at the heart of joe
biden's threat here
is not the fact that unvaccinated people
are dying every day
it's the fact that people are always
going to die every day
because people are going to die because
you can't avoid death
because there are certain hard facts
about this world that you
are not going to escape no matter no
matter
whether you give your consent or not
you're probably not going to consent to
die but you're going to die anyway
someday we all are this is a finite
world
okay and the the liberal modern society
wants to deny that fact of death and it
gets people so terrified of it that they
will
give away all their rights and shut down
the whole country for a year and a half
because of a virus because of a virus
that
you know it's not great but it's not
worse than many other pandemics that
we've gone through
but they're willing to give it all away
because of their terror of death and
because of their shock and because of
their delusion
that they are totally 100 in control of
their own lives
they own their own lives they can do
whatever they want they can as long as
it's consensual they can do whatever
they want darn it
no you didn't choose to come into this
world you're probably not going to
choose to come out of this world a lot
of things are going to happen to you in
the meantime
that are unjust i think this has to do
with a lot of the
crazy leftist entitlement culture and
the burning down of the country over the
grievance politics is people don't
recognize
it there is injustice in this world and
you're going to have to deal with that
that's a fact of life
and demagogues such as dr fauci and such
as joe biden
are exploiting that neurosis
that delusion that
refusal to to recognize basic facts of
reality
to control your life you know we want to
continue to include you in our future
plans
every day on this show i talk about
some terrific products and services from
sponsors that i love and use
we want to get to know you better so we
can choose our sponsors with you in mind
so
please head on over to dailywire.com
knowles fill out my audience survey to
tell us a little more about yourself
and to sweeten the whole experience
those of you that complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1
000 gift card you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show
so if you want to increase your chances
of winning one thousand dollars go
listen to ben shapiro andrew clavin or
matt walsh
to get their surveys as well go to
dailywire.com
knowles we would love to hear from you
also if you didn't catch last night's
episode of candace
you seriously don't want to miss it you
can still watch her full interview with
president donald trump if you're a daily
wire member
they discuss everything from the media's
attacks against him and melania
to whether he is going to run for
president 2024 and he actually gives a
lot of information to candace
if you've not joined daily wire yet
hurry now this is your last chance to
get 25
off a new membership with code candice
before the discount ends tomorrow and
you'll also be able to check out a
really
i would say really handsome articulate
brilliantly insightful swarthy guest
on on candace's most recent episode so
head on over there we'll be right back
with a lot more
joe biden's case for getting the vaccine
is that if you don't get the vaccine
you're you're likely to die
basically people are dying every day you
got to get it
forget about your own risk assessment
forget about prudence and your own
faculties of reason you got to get it
okay
okay that's about as strong a pitch as
you can possibly make
so mr president how do we get the
vaccine
let me repeat we're going to make it
easier than ever to get vaccinated
visit vaccines.com.gov
vaccines.com or text to
your text your zip code to
438829-438829
i uh i'm just gonna clear out my ear a
little bit
uh can we one more time where
how do you get the vet where do you go
get the vaccine let me repeat
we're going to make it easier than ever
to get vaccinated
visit vaccines.com.gov
vaccines.com or text to
your text your zip code to
438829-438829
i want to be very careful here because
this is a family program
uh so all i will say is that
i am i am less likely to get the
vaccine after that pitch that was not a
very not a very persuasive pitch
from uh joe biden dr fauci who is the
leader of the the coronavirus
initiative here right he's the he's the
one leading the public health response
finally dr fauci it's been not just two
weeks
not just two months it's been a long
been a long time pal can we we can
finally get back to normal right
we let you we'll let you drag this thing
on
about 28 or 29 times
longer than you said it would take
finally we can go back to normal right
we're at the end of the pandemic
we would hope by the time we get to the
end of calendar year 2021
and the beginning of the first quarter
of 2022
we'll be able to vaccinate children of
any age before i let you go dr fauci you
and i
are a major league of baseball fans uh
what inning are we in as far as this
coveted pandemic is concerned
well you know i i we're at least halfway
through
i i hope we're seeing and and i do
believe uh
uh wolf i'm not trying to be overly uh
enthusiastic about what's going on
vis-a-vis the vaccine program which is
so successful
but we've really got to not declare
victory prematurely
so we're in the late innings but it's
not over that's the thing we really got
to get people to appreciate
we're going in the right direction we're
seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel but now is not a time to declare
victory
it's a time to get more and more people
vaccinated just the way the president
said today
we want to get to that goal it's a
doable goal and i believe we'll get
there so you think the seventh the
eighth inning or late innings
what anything you're talking about how
about the the bottom of the sixth
try that one i'll go with the bottom of
the six that's not too bad
now i don't think that dr fauci has a
ton of credibility
on the virus because he has admitted
that he
has misled us remember in that first
few weeks where he said do not wear the
masks you stupid idiots do
again i'm i'm paraphrasing don't wear
them the masks do nothing
idiots and then a few weeks later he
says you have to wear the masks
and we all said well uh-huh what changed
and he said oh
i wanted to make sure there was enough
masks for all my friends in public
health
but now there is so it's cool wear the
mask you have to
and you think well dr fauci if you would
be so
deeply misleading and dishonest to us
about
that basic protective element early on
why should we trust you now
but so i i don't think he has a ton of
credibility on this this virus
but i know he has no credibility on
baseball
because if you recall he was chosen to
throw the first pitch out at the nats
game
some months ago and he dribbled the
pitch he just
went like was it right down the first
base line it was not not great
and also by the way at that game he wore
the mask on the pitcher's mound when he
was
far away from everybody and then when he
got back up in the stands and he thought
the tv cameras weren't on him he was
sitting next to friends of his friends
whom he doesn't live
with right friends were not part of his
household and he took the mask down and
he wasn't even eating he was just
hanging out
so not a ton of credibility but he's
going to hold his power
that's what this is about not two not
two weeks in not two months in we're now
over well over a year in dr fauci says
we're going to be two years in and
he's still not going to give up his
power bottom of the sixth
how much more do you need to see
what else does he need to tell us before
it is clear they're not going to give up
this power this was a power grab
on behalf of the liberal state which
expresses itself through the
bureaucracy and notably through the
public health bureaucracy because public
health
justifies anything that the
the left wants to do
they are they're grabbing that power and
they're going to force us into
vaccine passports they're going to which
is effectively coercing the vaccine
they're going to force us into boosters
they're going to force us into more
lockdown measures they're going to
for they're going to maintain their
stranglehold on business
on church on civil society on voting
totally up into the voting system
because of kovid remember now we have
widespread mainlands even in states
where that is unconstitutional like
pennsylvania
now you've got dropboxes now election
day becomes election
year i don't know election week election
month they just keep expanding it
that's what we're headed toward and
their argument by the way
is has has a slight bit of truth to it
which is private decisions have public
effect
and that's true we it is not enough for
us to say
my body my choice right that is the
argument that the left or that the right
rather has made
on matters of public health
uneven vaccines my body my choice
they're just making the abortion
argument
but with with a little more
persuasiveness because it really does
have to do with your body you're not
killing another human in there
but the decision of whether or not to
get vaccinated
in theory does affect everybody else
but then you have to get to the i think
more persuasive conservative argument
which is
the prudential argument i want to talk
about this vaccine i want to talk about
this virus i want to talk about this
country right now
where lots and lots of people have been
vaccinated
where lots and lots of people have
antibodies where the death rate is
much lower than we feared in the
beginning of this thing
i want to talk about those particulars
because in those particulars
if you are a young healthy person who's
weighing risk who's
making a prudential judgment you're
going to have a very different
conclusion than if you're living i don't
know during the black plague where
some huge percentage of europe is
getting wiped wiped out
because of that pandemic
we're probably not even going to be
allowed to get that kind of information
because
the blob the liberal establishment
is teaming up with the private sector
talk about breaking down
distinctions between public and private
you've now got the government the public
sector
teaming up with big tech the private
sector
to censor the right to censor
conservatives
and to dominate the political order
officials from the california secretary
of state alex padilla's office
have have now been exposed for
complaining to social media companies
about posts that they didn't like that
contained misinformation regarding the
administration
of california's elections or that just
made political points they
that they did not prefer and now we have
these records thanks to judicial watch
which does
fabulous work they through the
california public records act got these
records the secretary of state's office
apparently
combed through social media posts
flagging content from users with even
very small followings
and even videos that had only a couple
thousand views
in some cases according to reports for
no other reason
uh then because the officials disagreed
with the opinions expressed
build your own facebook michael come on
you you know that the squish
conservatives who are either extremely
ignorant or useful idiots
you know court jester conservatives
whose sole purpose is to prop up the
dominant liberal regime
they will say no michael facebook's a
private company
twitter is a private company youtube
google google is a private company
they control the flow of information
around the public square but they're a
private company
and so you can't ever and if they look
if they want to consent
to working on behalf of the liberal
establishment through the secretary of
state of california's office that's
totally that's
their consent that's their decision to
make
these private matters are are really
starting to sound like political matters
to me
public matters public and political mean
the same thing maybe it's time for
conservatives to exercise our
our personal choice in the political
sphere
to bring these people into line through
the political process
because what we're seeing right now is a
totally
rigged game and conservatives have given
away that game by buying the left's
stupid propaganda about personal choices
it's a private matter it's a personal
choice give me a break
speaking of social media platforms
president trump has one coming up
he does it's not people are kind of
disappointed with trump's social media
platform because we were hoping
he was going to make his own google he
was going to make his own facebook
he's a billionaire president of the
united states
he can command at least 70 million
people to
take what he's doing seriously and
instead what we got was effectively a
blog
so he unveiled the new social media
platform it's just donaldj trump.com
desk and it's just his own posts so some
people are really disappointed about
this
i'm not i actually think it's hilarious
i think it is pique trump to say we're
going to have this great new platform
now that i've been d-platformed
from twitter and facebook and social
media we're gonna have a new platform
and then what's the platform it's just
his blog
with giant buttons that say share to
twitter and facebook and all over so
it's just a way to troll
the big tech companies and get back in
there it was not
executed very well so the only problem i
have with i don't have a problem that
it's a modest sort of blog i don't have
a problem that's only one way that it's
just trump
communicating to us my only problem is
it's not optimized for maximum
trollishness
because if you try to if you go to the
website right now and you try to share
you click the share button to twitter
it it doesn't work it actually won't
share so then you got to click the link
and then share it directly on twitter
which is
taking too many steps out but then when
you share the link
it's just the picture of trump shows up
and then the kind of boilerplate
copy in the bottom of what president
trump has done and then only in the
headline
of the post do you see the first few
words of whatever
pseudo-tweet he has made which is always
very very funny so i just think if
you're going to do
i like the idea but you got to make it
very very easy to share
and functional and you've got to make
the whole
post just a way to infiltrate social
media so instead of the picture of trump
it should just be a picture of the text
of the post and instead of the
boilerplate copy at the bottom it should
just be the text it'd just be
all of the tweet so that donald trump
can
effectively tweet again and post on
facebook again
and then you force the big tech
company's hand to
ban any posts from this one website
which i think makes trump look really
great
and i think shows you the
the real end game here of this
censorship which is any conservative
who's actually going to make a point
they're going to have to to shut them
down i think it would be good
politically for trump
if he is serious about running in 2024
and by the way during his conversation
with candace
sure sounded like he's serious if he
wants to do that then he's gonna have to
he's gonna have to ratchet up that
trollishness
why wouldn't trump run in 2024 look who
he's running against
joe biden i guess
would run again he hasn't said that he's
going to step down he actually
probably needs to run again because if
if the the end game here is to get
kamala in
i don't think kamala can win on her own
she's very very unlikable even among
democrats she was
one of if not the first democrat out of
the primary race in
2020 and i said you'll remember i said
from the very beginning watch kamala
she's a clever politician
and when she got booted out of the race
everyone said oh michael you're an idiot
i can't believe you thought kamala was
going places
and she did she did that call was
totally right
but she still is very unpopular so
probably what needs to happen is
biden needs to get reelected and then
handed over to kamala
if trump runs against joe biden this is
the kind of guy that he's up against
the last thing americans with around
with the amount of wealth
needs is another tax break we need to
make a choice to eliminate the loophole
only the gains above for people only the
gains above people making two million
dollars a year
but i've seen a couple a rate of capital
gains rate for people making more than a
million dollars a year
which by the way would affect three
tenths of one percent of all taxpayers
three tenths of one percent of the top
one percent and close another loophole
like the real estate investor loophole
the wealthiest simply paying the same
rate
on their wages of investment income that
raises 40
billion dollars a year for the next 10
years
the reason i'm bothering to do this is i
keep hearing on the press biden's going
to raise your taxes
anybody making less than hundred
thousand dollars a year will not pay a
single
penny in taxes and we will not increase
the deficit either
unlike the last gigantic tax cut which
increased the deficit by two trillion
dollars
wait hold on no nobody
making under uh 400 000
a year will pay a single penny in taxes
i might need to rethink my political
affiliation that's pretty good you don't
you don't have to pay anything because
right now i'm paying almost half of my
money away in taxes but i don't have to
oh that's oh no that's not what he meant
he he meant that they won't pay any what
any more or any what is that
it's hard to translate from biden into
english because not only does it come
out garbled because he's just exhausted
obviously and passed his prime but he
also just doesn't know
what he is talking about more and more
confusion but
if joe biden runs for re-election if
donald trump
runs for re-election oh man
they're gonna have some competition no
i'm not talking about
kamala desantis cruz holy
whoever anybody who's going to run i'm
talking about the real competition
can you smell what the rock is cooking
there's a part of young rock
as if you're running for president in
2032.
a lot of people are reading a lot of
things into that well let me take
another drink of taramana before i
answer that one
it always helps with the answer i have a
goal
and an interest in ambition to unite our
country if this is what the people want
then i will do that and this goes back
to me wrestling
in flea markets and used car dealerships
and even in that as small and as
intimate and as rowdy as those crowds
were willie i still
had my finger on the pulse of the people
and i always got an idea of what they
wanted
in that moment so i say that to say like
if the time comes
where there is a good amount of people
who want to see that happen then i'm
going to consider it
how will you know if the people are
asking you to take that step
i think you would do deep dives of
polling and things like that and what
the people want will lead and inform
that decision
and if it is in fact what they want then
i'm going to take another drink of my
tarmana and i'm going to say okay let's
do it
tara monetary monetary money you got to
give the guy credit for being
a an a-list salesman he's pushing this
tequila that he's
he's using which raises questions about
uh this tequila that he owns rather it
raises questions about whether or not
he's serious about running
is he just using the buzz of the
president thing
to sell tequila he's got a big terramana
sign behind him he opens up the answer
talking about ceremony he closes the
answer talking about taramana
so maybe this is what people said about
trump for years they said oh he's just
trying to sell his
brand he's trying to sell his neckties
he's trying to sell
his memberships at his golf clubs he's
trying to sell us
the apprentice whatever he's just
pretending to run for president
so that he can do this i'm sure that the
rock realizes first of all i'm sure he's
paid attention to what trump did
and realizes that it is a good strategy
and it can help you
as a matter of business but also the
rock has floated this for years
he has been floating the idea of running
for president for a very very long time
and he has dipped his toes into politics
for a while he was a sort of a moderate
he was considered a moderate republican
he endorsed biden and harris in
2020. so i don't really like the rock i
don't think i would vote for the rock
his politics i don't think are my
politics
but i also don't like his answer i think
this answer is
everything wrong with politics
would you run for president well i'd
just have to pull
i'd have to take a lot of polls would
you run if the people want me to run
okay we hear that kind of silly jargon
there's
silly propaganda you know from from
candidates a lot i would only
run if i were called on to do it and i
would reluctantly
accept but but the rock actually takes
it further he says i would just pull and
i would pull and i would pull
and then if more people wanted me to run
than didn't want me to run
then i would run that's not
leadership that's not what people want
that is actually bad politics
people don't vote for you because you
just
say you'll do whatever they want people
vote for you
because you stand for something i
remember this i remember this in middle
school student government elections
you'd see some people get up there and
seriously
11 12 years old they get up there and
say i'll do whatever you want me to do
just please elect me
and the the thinking of very
shallow political thinkers is oh if i
just promise to give the people whatever
they want
then they're more likely to vote for me
but actually i think they're less likely
to vote for you then
because it just shows that you don't
stand for anything you don't believe in
anything
the rock's whole pitch his whole
political pitch is i'm a centrist
i'm a i'm a i'll just do whatever
whatever 50
plus one want to be done that's what
i'll do oh so you don't stand for
you're a big tough guy you're extremely
charismatic you're very good looking
you're very famous you're very rich
but you don't stand for anything why on
earth would i vote for you
i'd be more likely to vote perhaps
for an honest democrat because at least
i know what i'm getting i have no idea
what i'm getting with the rock
the rock might end up being much further
left because he's just going to go
wherever the wind blows
really really bad pitch speaking of
leadership got to get to this
you know that there's this problem in
the republican leadership in the house
namely liz cheney is a member of
leadership but she
hates republicans she clearly is disdain
for her
constituents she voted for the second
farcical impeachment of donald trump
she says that she parrots democrat
talking points all the time about the
big lie
uh which she says that if you in any way
question the 2020 election you're
engaging in the big
lie this was a phrase popularized by
democrats it refers to
something coined by adolf hitler in mein
kampf and ironically
when hitler uses the term the big lie in
mineconf he's actually
accusing the jews of propagating a big
lie to blame a
certain german general for the loss in
world war one so
ironically though the left doesn't is
not aware of this
when when they use this phrase they're
actually casting themselves
as the nazis in their own analogy
neither here nor there liz cheney
totally going along with this kind of
rhetoric and kevin mccarthy has
previously defended her he's the
actual the number one republican leader
in the house
apparently uh kevin mccarthy is is uh
losing his patience with with liz cheney
do we have the clip i think she's got
real problems
i i i've had it with i've had it with
it's you know i've lost confidence well
someone just has to bring a motion but i
assume that would probably take place so
this
was uh reportedly in the crosstalk
uh kevin mccarthy was on with uh steve
ducey from fox news
and what happens when you're on these
shows and i've been on fox news many
many times
before the interview goes live on tv
you're just talking to people you're
talking to the audio engineer sometimes
you're talking to the hosts
and that's supposed to be a private
conversation well
since we're only hearing kevin's side of
it here maybe someone in the room
happened to be recording it
maybe mccarthy himself is recording it
to who knows
but this private conversation is leaked
out
to the public and that private view is
probably going to have public effects
and liz cheney thankfully will hopefully
be out of
of republican leadership by the end of
the month
but a good reminder a nice little bow on
the end to remind us that our private
actions or private thoughts or
our private deeds have public effect
and vice versa and we need to start
thinking much more deeply about that we
need to ditch this shallow language of
you do you shallow language of total
privacy to do
to do whatever you want no matter how
vicious no matter the public effect
if we want to actually conserve anything
at all i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show
you